search and rescue efforts in uman
Ukraine are still underway after a
Russian missile slammed into a
residential apartment building you can
see some of the aftermath all of the
destroyed cars you can see the building
behind it still smoking this attack
happened at about 4 30 local time when
many people were sleeping in this
building the death toll has climbed all
morning starting at 10 then by afternoon
getting to 20 rescue efforts still
underway people we have spoken to on the
scene say they are still hopeful that
possibly they'll find some survivors for
now they're focusing their work on
digging through apartments in the
basement level before they make their
way up to some of the apartments on the
higher floor you can see where those
floors just collapsed on top of each
other's this missile strike that was
launched overnight it wasn't just this
city that was targeted targeted it was a
number of cities across Ukraine from the
capital city to Newport grow this was
the largest missile attack Russian
forces have launched in about two months
Russia's Ministry of Defense they claim
that the overnight missile strikes they
were high Precision strikes that were
targeting deployments areas where
Ukrainian forces have Reserve troops
Reserve supplies but this area from
everything we have seen this is a
residential area we have spoken to a
number of people and seen everyone who
lived in this building they were people
sleeping in the middle of the night
waking up to the sound of air raid
sirens and then explosions work here
will continue likely throughout the rest
of the day and possibly through the
night